nananana it's me I am down in Florida
visiting my mom my mom 70s gonna be 71
next month so I came down to Florida the
other night and I took my mom to see
Dolly Parton I've seen Dolly Parton
three times now in the span of three
months so I could sing Parton I could
sink two doors down like right now knock
your socks off you'd be like who knew
that that fat piece of [ __ ] could
[ __ ] sing not as well as Dolly Parton
but any Dolly Parton songs whatsoever
okay so where am i right now I met my
brothers is my brother's backyard
Florida's got these things like mosquito
nets over everything and [ __ ] like that
because otherwise it's a cup I don't
know it was this she has been here
procedure in any event I'm down here
visiting my mom heading back you know
tomorrow because we're shooting what's
in the box that I do have on screen
junkies channel and some new fat man on
Batman and I was sitting around talking
to my brother and this morning and I was
talking about cuz I was signing blu-ray
covers DVD covers for yoga as oars now
available at Jay and Silent Bob's secret
stash online so sign a bunch of covers
with DVD covers blu-ray covers with my
brother we're talking about I have to
get home to do as I said fat man bad man
he said what he gonna talk about I was
like I don't know but last episode of
fat man I'm Batman I talked about
wanting to do like not wanting to do but
like wouldn't it be great if they redid
Bedknobs and Broomsticks which is an old
Disney movie from 1972 that I absolutely
love that features which is against
Nazis if that doesn't sound like the
most metal [ __ ] movie you've ever
heard of
let me layer this on top of it they use
dead soldiers to fight their [ __ ] a
war like come on suits of armor fighting
each other and [ __ ] it's like like Game
of Thrones plus Harry Potter plus like
something else Walking Dead plus you
know not see the History Channel like oh
it's fantastic in any event we were on
the podcast me and Martin are nuts that
they should remake that because they've
remade peach dragon the de beauty's
I said Disney should remake that and
then I was like if Disney is gonna
remake I'll suck I said Disney I'll suck
dick to make the remake of Bedknobs and
Broomsticks and very facetious comment I
don't I wouldn't really suck dick for it
I'm not saying that never suck dick but
not for that job not for any [ __ ] job
if I suck dick it's gonna be for passion
and love in any event you know it's just
something that something like I think
it's a good idea they remake Bedknobs
and Broomsticks so there were a bunch of
articles online this weekend bloggers
going like Kevin Smith wants to remake
Bedknobs and Broomsticks which at first
I was like no I don't but I was like
well I want it to be remade and if they
were doing it that'd be amazing if it
was me but technically does that all add
up to like you know I'm not campaigning
for it if that's the case thankfully
most of the articles were like you know
even he understands that this is a long
shot I I don't even think it's a shot
that's my point in any event I needed to
tell you that story so I could tell you
this story so I'm down here visiting my
mom has said I'm having a wonderful time
and stuff my brother lives down here in
Florida as well and I'm signing these
covers and so I'm telling them that
story I go let me show you dude let me
show you I said this gets out gross
because I'm a Google me but let me
Google me and hit news and let me show
you there's like [ __ ] six articles
about Bedknobs and Broomsticks who's me
and my brother loved Bedknobs
broomsticks my brothers gays days Long's
been married to his husband Jerry since
1994 so their marriages as old as clerks
they were doing a gay married thing long
before the rest of the country and
whatnot but he loves Angela Lansbury
like you read about in I do too Sweeney
Todd and she was the star of Bedknobs
and Broomsticks so I'm like hey man
[ __ ] you got to read these kooky
articles about we should remake bedrock
Bedknobs and Broomsticks and how I just
really want to remake it and stuff but
that's not really what the articles were
about but anyway I was like this'll make
you laugh so in order to do that I enter
enter my name into Google which is
something I never do you would imagine I
do that all the time
I don't terrified of what will pop up
like [ __ ] today so I entered Kevin
Smith and there I saw Ben Dobbs
Broomsticks article there was a few
articles about flash the recent flash
that I directed then there was an
article that said something about
buckaroo banzai and it was from today
and it was from The Hollywood Reporter
and I can't get to it cause I'm doing
Facebook live but essentially the Holly
reporter said that MGM is suing the
creators of buckaroo banzai
Alma crock and NWD Richter so that I
could make my buckaroo banzai TV show so
this was surprising because this is the
first that I heard about this not that
there was a buckaroo banzai TV show yes
we were all hoping to do that but I had
no idea they were gonna sue the
creator's a buckaroo banzai had to do
that now that's whether that's right or
not is not for me to say you know that
you've got two parties that maintain
they own something and whatnot but you
got to remember from the moment and so
I'm not jumping in that legal about I
don't you know I don't figure out who
owns that apparently they're going to
court but my point is I'm not going to
court I love the people at MGM they've
treated me insanely well all across this
project with real credibility and stuff
like that like you know they thought I
could redo this show even when I didn't
think I could and the folks at Amazon
have been lovely as well but you got to
remember like this has there's no
production yet no scripts been turned
and I'm better paid to dime no money has
been really spent so it's not like you
know we're going to upend a lot of
things like this legal thing came out of
nowhere I did not know about this I
called that my agent I was like what the
[ __ ] is this and here's my thing like I
love all the people at MGM Amazon's got
nothing to do with us but MGM is is that
the lawsuit came from their legal
department but the only reason I love
buckaroo banzai is because of those two
guys because of Earl McGraw if I'm
saying that right and WD Richter that's
why I fell in love with that movie when
I saw it back in like 1984 like it was
magical were 86 84 when I saw it magical
because there was nothing else like it
that work came from an amazing singular
vision or a vision of those two men and
when I got the job if you go back and
look at my Instagram feed I was like I
can't wait to do this I want to involve
Earl McGraw and WG Richter I did gave
interviews where I talked about I want
to get Earl right in the script and WD
to direct an episode because I wasn't
gonna direct all the episodes and stuff
so
without those two dudes I don't I don't
I don't fall in love with that property
and I'm a creator myself like you know
essentially the situation that has just
happened completely unawares like I read
about it I'm a Hollywood Reporter like
an hour ago or whatever [ __ ] news to me
but essentially what is going on is MGM
is asserting that they own the property
and I don't know if they I'm sure they
do they've been saying that since the
beginning but in order to make sure that
that's official they have to you know
essentially bring action against the two
creators of that's what this lawsuit is
it comes to the MGM legal doesn't come
from any of the people I met at MGM and
stuff but from legal department so that
may be the case but I can't I don't want
it like I don't want to make anything
unless those dudes are Bob they had the
vision like all we're doing is like
taking their amazing vision and making a
TV show of it and this is I don't like
you know I can't with all due respect
this sucks oh my god this sucks so hard
because we had a pretty much a put show
not put show but like we had script
orders and stuff like that but I can't I
can't like I'm not that guy like here
and we put it to you in terms that I
perceived it as that instantly [ __ ]
stopped my heart let's say one day two
people that own Miramax now it's not
Harvey and Bob and stuff but the folks
that own new Miramax wherever new
Miramax is someone's like hey we want to
make clerks and I'm like well I don't
want you to make clerks you know not
while I'm alive please don't and then
they sue me to stop to make sure that
they can make clerks without you know me
being involved because around comes
around in life and stuff and I'm not
saying anybody's wrong in this situation
but I I'm what I'm saying is
respectfully to all parties involved I'm
out
I can't again I wanted those dudes
involved in the show and stuff so that
this kind of goes against what we all
talked about and not goes again it's
just I don't know things happen this
didn't exist when we made the deal and
now it does and so sadly as much as I
would love to continue my god you know I
love this movie
and another bunch of people online like
don't touch it you suck and stuff I get
I understand people think I suck at my
job but just because people to suck your
job doesn't mean you give up the
opportunity of a lifetime but you give
up the opportunity of a lifetime
if you know you just like I can't do
that to those dudes that created that
show and I didn't know that's what was
gonna happen here and stuff so I'm not
saying like MGM's wrong I'm Jim should
do whatever they must to protect their
copyright and trademarks and stuff like
that but this was not what I signed up
for so with all due respect and please
like and when you write about it don't
be like a fiery Smith if I was fiery
about anything it was Bedknobs and
Bedknobs and Broomsticks okay please put
that in the article
I was not fiery about this but I was
shocked like that caught me off guard
here I'll give you some quotes I was
caught off guard
I had no literally no idea I went to the
Internet to look up a Bedknobs and
Broomsticks news story found out that
there was a lawsuit involving buckaroo
banzai so you know I do this through
official channels and stuff but this is
just so everybody out there knows
because immediately of course they're a
bunch of people like how could he do
this
how could Kevin Smith do this to the
creators buckaroo banzai the answer is
and I'm not being a first person dick
I'm just answering their questions Kevin
Smith can't do that
I wouldn't I got just like so so a blows
man because that's the closest I've had
to have my own show so far man like you
know so far we've pitched Mallrats a few
places there's some new news pitch
Mallrats few places no bites and stuff
that buckaroo banzai thing was for real
son so it sucks to walk away from
something for real and I know some
people are out there like [ __ ] get
over it and do it and blah blah blah
it's money and but there's other ways to
make money as well I could stay on stage
and talk to people and they'll pay me
and stuff like that and I won't sit
there and know that because of me the
people that created something I've loved
since my teenage years are hurting
because of something that I'm even
remotely involved in so I've read a
bunch of articles on lines incorrect
kept calling Kevin Smith's buckaroo
banzai on some of the snark your
websites of course came through with
like these guys getting sued so Kevin
Smith can make his buckaroo banzai
that's not true so I'm my buckaroo
banzai belongs to MGM and as of this
this telling yes that's I'm I'm no
longer and
I'm not on wishing anybody harm I wish
all parties well I hope those dudes come
to an agreement and if they do and they
still want me involved down the road I'm
I'll be here but why would they at the
end of the day and stuff I understand
but I this one this is not the way I
want to succeed in life I don't you know
I'm this is gonna sound weird but I
fancied myself a self-made person and I
didn't get here you know you may not
like to [ __ ] I do and that's fine and
stuff like
speaking of which yoga is now on blu-ray
but you know I got here there's a moment
of madmen which I love [ __ ] love the
show madmen
but remember when Don Draper I was gonna
say remember when the mavs man
remember when Don Draper met Conrad
Hilton and so they were friends for like
conv season and then Conrad Hilton told
Don Draper that they're gonna sell your
agency and stuff and you're all going to
McCann and Don Draper started to get
cash Eddie with with con with Conrad
Hilton and Connery and the actor who
played him was amazing I can't [ __ ]
remember what his name is but he goes he
says to John Draper we good he looks at
more hard and [ __ ] and then bemused and
he's like you know I got everything I
have on my own it has made me immune to
those who complain and cry because they
can't so I love that moment in that show
I think it's brilliant quote and stuff I
have everything I've made I'm on my own
there have been people who bought my
work and put me in places but I made
that stuff by myself I'm still creative
but you know I may not have good ideas
anymore but I have ideas so I could
still come up with like another shot
another bite at the apple of my own show
of some sort I can't do it on the back
of somebody that whose work I respect so
much and and they're not an active
participants stuff
so again if you're gonna write about
this and some people will they'll write
about it without the without this I mean
it's a fact free world now don't matter
but since you got a factual document me
saying these words I was not fiery I'm
not mad at anybody I'm disappointed
because I wish this would have happened
and we all work together but then I hope
those cats work it out and they can work
together but if there's a lawsuit
involved which is come
fleet news to me literally learned about
at same time you did have just lost
about an hour and changed from my time
with my mom because I'm dealing with
this but yeah not for me there's other
ways to do it I got a lot of stuff to do
that sounds braggy I don't like this was
huge
this was doing buckaroo banzai was a big
deal to me on so many levels so I'm not
saying you know feel bad for me I hurt
but I do but you know do the right thing
that's the point of today's motivation
you know sometimes doing the right thing
sucks and I'm not saying the wrong thing
would have been staying involved or
whatever because again that rights
issues between everybody else but I felt
it would be wrong to do that like again
I just put it through my prism that's we
got doing life for you make a move that
might affect somebody unduly or you know
hurt them or something like that or or
even make their lives uncomfortable that
much put yourself through their prism
then like put yourself in their shoes
and be like what happens if this happens
to me in the moment I read about this in
The Hollywood Reporter I started
thinking about of course selfishly my
job oh my god my job like buckaroo
banzai like what's going to happen and
stuff but then I immediately put myself
on the other side of the equation going
like okay I'm the guy that made clerks
and somebody wants to make clerks
without me like you know you wouldn't
support that fact keV Smith that's what
I said to myself and so I can I'm not
saying I'm a creature of huge integrity
but I'm saying it sucks not to be the
guy that's like you know hey man
everyone else be damned I'm looking out
for me in mine because I got mouths to
feed son and I would like to do a TV
show too but you know what there let me
play over at the CW man I got to do
flash and and I did a Supergirl which is
coming up in January and stuff so I'm
happy to play in somebody else's the
world until maybe one day somebody's
like twing you got a show there's moose
jaw's coming up
you know after tusks and and yoga hose
there's moose jaw's jaws with a moose
instead of a shark there's and there's
other things that I still haven't talked
about publicly yes that's right I still
keep them some things quiet
so you know there's some stuff to look
forward to and whatnot but sucks losing
this one but you know one of my favorite
movies in the world Spike Lee's do the
right thing and the mayor says it Mugi
what always do the right thing that it
that's it I got it
I'm done always do the right thing and
again that's not me saying this is not
again I don't want to get screwed over
and people being like he said [ __ ] it
was the wrong thing it's wrong for me to
be involved in anything that hurts the
creators of something that I love and am
interested in remaking you see the weird
[ __ ] loop here right so I'm over
speaking at this point I'm gonna go back
and hang out in my mom man go back to
mom son fun stuff and whatnot and then
tomorrow shoot more what's in the box
for screen junkies and then more fat man
I'm Batman which maybe we'll talk about
this on there as well hopefully not
hopefully we'll have moved on but for
the record I'm stepping off of buckaroo
banzai
there you go I could have just said that
in the beginning but detail always helps
thanks for hanging out that's today's
motivation which is not quit your job
that's not it at all believe him this
one [ __ ] hurts my mother is litter in
the other room going Tiger you know but
you know mom's used to disappointment
I'm her son and you know I got to wake
up with me every day and part of the
reason I'm creative at all or inventive
at all or have the weird sense of humor
I have it all is because of that movie
and because those two gentlemen so you
know can't I can't they're not involved
I'm not involved and right now it looks
like they're not involved so I hope it
keeps going forward it should it's
amazing buckaroo banzai is fantastic but
but not right not with me okay
that's it everyone have a great day go
hang out with your mothers that's what
I'm gonna do right now
I was gonna just tell you what I was
gonna do with my mother but some people
be like it ruins the credibility of
everything he just like talked about
here in his video and stuff but we're
gonna we're just gonna drive around and
look at ice cream prices seventy dude
like 70 my mother like this she has
simple pleasures now so like I there's a
new ice cream place so that's it thank
god she's not like take me to get [ __ ]
Tiger get me laid tiger take me to the
male brothel
let me dangle with a stranger and [ __ ]
so you know I scream at Shelby
there it is folks thanks for hanging out